good morning Hank it's Tuesday old
school blog with this video where I sit
down with no idea what I'm going to talk
about about what I'm going to talk
whatever sometimes you need to end a
sentence with a preposition okay so a
while ago I was getting dressed for a
cocktail party I was putting on like
proper fancy pants and everything I was
looking at myself in the mirror and I
said to Sara I feel like I look like a
middle-aged man in this outfit and then
Sara pause for like a quarter second too
long before saying no no no you look
great and I realized I look like a
middle-aged man because I am a
middle-aged man like if I died at double
my current age people won't be like oh
it's a tragedy they'll be like yeah he
had a good run could have been better
wasn't terrible but they're about middle
ages then if you triple your current age
and that's like a reasonable age for a
human being to be then you're not yet
middle-aged I mean Hank you're 33 you
triple that you're 99 that's right on
the edge I'm 36 you tripled that that's
a hundred and eight living 208 doesn't
even seem like a good outcome to me
anyway there are tons of obviously
negative things about being middle-aged
but there are also some advantages you
know like the stability of adulthood and
the pleasure of parenting but the
biggest thing Hank is that no one
expects me to know anything about pop
culture which is great because I don't
and this brings us belatedly to Justin
Bieber to be honest with you Hank I know
this sounds crazy but I don't think I've
ever heard a Justin Bieber song actually
I'm gonna listen to like his top five
songs right now and see if I've ever
heard any of them hold on okay this
one's called boyfriend it has like three
hundred million views I haven't heard
this song before it's kind of good is he
a rapper too good talk I never heard it
before though all right let's see the
next one okay this one's called
this one's called one time he looks much
younger in this video I kind of like
this one as well although we just run
knock we'd stop yeah I never heard that
song before in my life okay let's see
what's next
beauty and a beat featuring Nicki Minaj
nope I have never heard beauty and to
beat
I'm gonna try one more it's the most
view to whenever it's called baby and it
features Ludacris seems familiar to me I
feel like I have heard this song before
I feel like I've heard it but I feel
like I've heard a cover of it or
something anyway that one is definitely
familiar baby featuring Ludacris is
familiar to me so there you have it I've
heard one Justin Bieber song I think and
yet despite my obvious and complete
ignorance of Justin Bieber and his work
I can tell you that Justin Bieber was
recently arrested for DUI driving a
rented Lamborghini and in fact I can
tell you
color of that neighbor gimme it with
yellow why do I know this Hank non
rhetorical question why do I know about
it
I have no investment in Justin Bieber I
mean I don't think you should drink and
drive but I don't think anyone should
drink and drive why do I know the color
of that Lamborghini why do I have the
image of britney Spears's shaved head
imprinted upon my mind where I might be
remembering I don't know how to speak
Dutch or something so I can feel like a
relatively small number of people raises
someone up to the level of celebrity and
then everyone gets to participate in
like relishing their downfall it seems
to me that Justin Bieber is now more
likely to be on the cover of tabloid
magazines than he was back when he was
doing really well like in the baby air
oh baby it's from your song Hank the ice
cream changes song I know it because if
your song if you know what I'm talking
about me gonna do we do but Hank I
haven't heard that Justin Bieber song I
only heard your cover of it I'm still
zero for Bieber or I was until I
listened to those songs anyway which I
quite liked Hank I don't want to excuse
anyone's behavior and I certainly don't
want to act like celebrity is the most
troubling form of oppression out there
but I do worry about the way we approach
celebrities problems with relish not so
much because it's bad for the
celebrities but because I think it might
be bad for us I don't think relentless
public chastising much helps anyone if
it did we would see this happen less and
we aren't I think it's really hard to
choose what we pay attention to but I
think in a lot of ways it's also one of
the most important choices we make so
here's to sober driving imagining others
complexly and not paying attention to
the colour of someone else's rented
Lamborghini Hank I'll see you on Friday